- [Instructor] We are used
to thinking about markets
for goods and services,
and demand and supply
of goods and services,
and what we're gonna do in
this video is broaden our sense
of what a market could be for
by thinking about the
market for loanable funds.
Now, this might seem like
a very technical term,
loanable funds, but it
literally just means funds
that people are supplying to
be lent out to other people
and funds that people are demanding
that they want to borrow.
And so, one way to
think about this market,
the suppliers in the
loanable funds market,
these are the savers.
So, when you go and save
some money, maybe at a bank,
that bank will then lend
that money to someone else
and because the bank is getting
interest from that person,
they can also afford to
pay you some interest,
so you get a return.
It doesn't always have
to be through a bank,
but that tends to be typical.
It will go through some
type of intermediary.
Similarly, who are the demanders
or where's the demand coming from?
I don't know if demanders is a real word,
but I'll just write it down.
So, where is the demand coming from?
Well, that is coming from the borrowers
who are interested in,
maybe, making an investment,
maybe some type of business opportunity
is available to them.
And as I mentioned, this isn't a market
where the suppliers and the demanders,
or the savers and the borrowers,
necessarily directly
interact with each other.
Every now and then you might get a loan
from your sister-in-law
or from your parents,
but oftentimes, usually,
it's going through some type
of institution, some type
of financial institution,
usually banks, where the savers
put their money in a bank
hoping, not just for save keeping,
but really to get a return on their money.
In order to provide a
return to those savers,
the bank will then lend
it out to borrowers
and charge interest to them.
And to appreciate this in the way
that we've looked at markets before,
I can set up two axes
and in any market that
we've looked at before,
the horizontal axis, this is the quantity,
and so here, we're
talking about the quantity
of loanable funds,
loanable
funds.
And then on the vertical axis,
we normally think about the price
for the good or service,
but when we're dealing
with loanable funds,
the price is the interest rate.
And if we want to know the real price,
we should be talking about
the real interest rate.
Real
interest
rate.
And so, let's think about
each of these scenarios.
Let's think about the savers
who are really the suppliers
in the loanable funds market.
When real interest rates are lower,
if real interest rates are low,
they don't wanna really
supply a lot of quantity.
They're not getting,
not a lot of motivation
to be a supplier, to
save in that situation.
But if real interest rates are high,
well, then they might say,
I'm more likely to save and I
wanna make my funds available
for loaning out to other people
'cause I get this great interest rate,
especially when it's a real interest rate.
So, we could view it
as something like this.
This we could call our
supply of loanable funds
and you could imagine
what the demand curve
for loanable funds looks like.
When real interest rates are high,
people say, hey, you know,
there aren't that many
business opportunities
that could justify borrowing
at that high of a rate,
so there wouldn't be much
quantity that is demanded.
But as the real interest rates,
or if the real interest rates
are lower, as they get lower,
then the quantity demanded of
loanable funds will be higher.
So, this is our demand for loanable funds
and like we've seen in the past,
you're going to have an
equilibrium quantity and price,
where price, in this situation,
is your real interest rate
and so that's going to
happen where these intersect.
This is our equilibrium quantity
and this is our equilibrium
real interest rate.
Now, let's think about
what would happen if one
or both of these curves
were to shift somehow.
And there's a couple of ways,
let's start with the
demand for loanable funds.
There's a couple of ways that the demand
for loanable funds curve could shift.
Maybe all of a sudden people
see new business opportunities.
Astroid mining is becoming a thing
and so people wanna
borrow money to get robots
and send them out into space
so they can mine asteroids
for platinum or something.
Well, what would happen?
Pause this video and think about that.
Well, then at any given
real interest rate,
there's gonna be a
higher quantity demanded.
So, in that situation, our demand
for loanable funds would
shift to the right.
It would look something like this.
So, this is demand for loanable funds,
I'll call it sub two.
Sometimes you'll see
something like a prime there,
but I'll call it sub two.
So, it has shifted to the right
because of new business opportunities.
Another common reason why that might shift
to the right is if maybe the government
is doing a lot more borrowing.
Remember, this is an
aggregate market here.
So, the government, when it borrows money
to fuel its spending, that also,
it has to go into the
loanable funds market
and so, increased government borrowing
would also shift this to the right.
And if the opposite happened,
if people thought there were
fewer business opportunities
or if the government
started to borrow less,
well, that would shift things to the left.
But let's just think
about what would happen.
If R is the current
equilibrium interest rate,
if that just stayed where it is,
well, then you're going to have a shortage
of loanable funds, where the
suppliers would be willing
to supply this quantity
while the borrowers are going
to want this quantity here
at that real interest rate.
And so what you're going to have happen is
you're gonna get to a
new equilibrium point.
The real interest rate is
going to go up to this point,
let's call that our new
equilibrium real interest rate,
and our quantity is going
to go up as well, so Q1.
In order to convince more suppliers
to part with their money,
not part with their money,
or at least make their
money available for lending,
well, the interest rate's
going to have to go up
and we get to that point right there.
Similarly, you could
have shifts in the supply
of loanable funds.
Let's say, for example,
the savings rate changes
for some reason.
There's a big marketing
campaign from the government
or in education or in schools that say,
hey, we need to save more for a rainy day.
You need to save more for our retirement.
Well, then the supply of loanable funds,
if everyone saves more at
any given real interest rate,
well, then the supply
for loanable funds curve
could shift to the right,
and if the opposite happened,
of course it would shift to the left.
Supply of loanable funds two,
and then what would happen?
Well, if we were at this
point right over here,
all of a sudden we are in a situation
where there's a surplus of loanable funds.
At this interest rate, people are willing
to supply way more loanable funds
than people are demanding,
so then the price of the loanable funds,
which is the real interest
rate, will go down.
It will go down to this
new equilibrium point,
and so here, this, we
could call this R sub three
would be our new real interest rate,
equilibrium real interest rate,
and this would be our
new equilibrium quantity.
Actually, let me call this
R sub two right over here.
So, I will leave you there.
The big takeaway is
that loanable funds kind
of operate the way the market
for almost anything would
with the difference being that the price
is no longer just a dollar amount,
it is an interest rate
and since we wanna factor out inflation,
it is a real interest rate.